So I'm going to get started on,
um,
as I lay dying. And, uh, as
with the sound of the fury, um,
there's, uh, very, um, uh,
kind of long genealogy, uh,
behind the title of the novel.
Once again,
there's a very learned
illusion, uh, behind the title,
and it doesn't go back to the Beth.
This time it goes back,
actually goes back farther. It
goes back to the Odyssey. Um,
and you guys might remember
said in book 11 of the Odyssey,
um,
bill ducs goes down to the
underworld and he sees all the,
he sees his mother,
uh,
but he also sees all the illustrators
dead from the Trojan war and amount of
debt that he talks to
his Agamemnon. And, uh,
we know that the mammo was killed when
he got back from the Trojan war. Um,
and so they see as ones to find out the
circumstances of his death and Mammo and
says, as I laid w
obviously translation, um,
as I lay dying the woman with the dogs,
I would not close my eyes
as I descended into hades.
Um, so it, um, there's no, um,
that's, that's a very good,
uh, record within the APIC.
It is also picked up in various Greek
tragedies because that's one of the
central tragedies, um, in, in
the classical world is, uh,
the killing of Agamemnon,
uh, bias, wife's lover.
But there's a long story behind dad's,
um,
the reason that Chitin Nestra and I
want you to remember that name because
Kaiser Nestor will come up again,
um, in light in August as a very,
um, no, actually, sorry, she
doesn't come up in later in August,
she comes up in another novel.
I'm in absolute Absalon,
so it's a name that is very
important to Faulkner, but, uh,
within the confines of
a, as I lay dying, uh,
Clyde nest or Ashley didn't just
want to kill her husband, you know,
to have an affair with producers.
She was actually a seeking revenge
for the killing of her daughter.
Ivision I, uh, uh, when the, uh, the,
the Greek ships were not able to
sell because there was a dead calm.
And so if should,
I was sacrificed by Agamemnon
in order to get them going.
Um, and she knows that
grievance for 10 years. Uh,
and so when Agamemnon comes home,
um,
he was with his mistress,
Cassandra from tri. Um,
he was killed by adjusters
with, uh, Chitum Nesta,
egging him on. So this is the, in many
ways, the sort of defining moment,
the defining tragic moment
in the classical world. Um,
and then numerous representations of that,
um,
of adjusters killing Agamemnon
with Patten, Lester looking on.
Um, and this is a really
handy, um, identifications, uh,
illustration for us, all the names given
to us. So a cleanliness, Nesta is there.
It's just this is the one who actually
does the killing at a [inaudible]
electrode is his daughter and
she will bring her brother back.
Wrist is to kill. It just is. So,
it really is back and forth killing,
um, across many generations. And
Cassandra will in time. Well,
we actually right there, uh,
be killed by cattle Astra.
So lots of violence, lots
of hatred. And this is, um,
the defining feature
of the House of Atreus.
So it's very important for Faulkner to
be referring back to this ancient epic a
moment. Um, because he's obviously
talking about a family, uh,
were fairly complicated
emotional relationships, right?
Is a family that is not
entirely defined by love. Um,
you know, we would like
families to be defined by love,
but usually most families are a little
bit more complicated than this. Um,
and in this case, the house of
the abundance that the family,
um, is infinitely more complicated
than just being defined by love,
even though it's on the other
hand, the social spectrum. So, um,
let's keep that epic tradition in mind,
but I also want to just to highlight,
um,
the immediate chronology for
the writing of as I lay dying.
Um, it's a very, very pat chronology,
basically for six months,
um,
from the summer of 1929 to January,
1930, less than six months.
Really. Um, a lot of things happen.
So June 20th, a thought
never married, has, um,
childhood sweetheart.
It's all of them. Um,
and there was only two months
after her divorce from her husband,
Paul Franklin, um, ferry. You know,
when something like that happens,
you just wonder, you know,
what the aftermath would be.
Uh, what led up to it? Um,
so anyway, two months after that
is a very hasty marriage, uh,
in many ways unseemly marriage.
Um,
and she brought to the marriage
two children with Cornell,
Franklin, Malcolm, and Victoria. Um,
then October the seventh,
1929,
the sound and the fury was published.
Uh,
and the few weeks after that
was to stock market crash.
That in many ways was anticipated
by the Jayson section in the sound,
the theory, and the
day after that, I mean,
if that was still going on
because the 24th was a Thursday,
so Friday was actually the official day
of the stock market crashed on that very
day.
Faulkner started writing as I lay dying.
So we can think of a better,
uh,
novel occasion by the Great Depression,
um,
to have and have not as
his title analysis. Um,
it's very much a great depression novel,
but as ELL as I lay dying is as well.
So we have to keep that in
mind. Um, and it was finished,
uh, really fast, um, in just
a few weeks. January 12,
1930, uh, as Ali, Diane was finished.
And [inaudible] talks about it.
He makes it very emphatic point
about how fast it was done. Um,
so in an interview with
Marshall Sniff, um, 1931,
he said, God, a job rolling
coal in a power plan,
found the sound of the dye them have
very conducive to literature road.
As I lay dying in a coat bunker beside
the diagonal between the working spouse
on the night shift,
finished it in six weeks.
Never change the word.
If I ever got rich,
I'm going to buy a dynamo
and put it in my house.
I think that would make writing easier.
So don't even shake is always, you know,
you should never trust a
word Faulkner says. Um,
but I think that there's some things that,
um,
not to be disputed and not
to be a fabricator. Um,
and that was the fact that he was
working, um, in a power plant,
working night shifts.
So this is very different from the
Faulkner that we might've imagined just by
looking at his house.
Um,
and I'm going to show you a picture
of his house a little later,
but, um, it, um,
it looks like a very stately house,
but actually when sophomore
first bought the house, um,
it was decrepit and was deemed
unfit for human habitation. Um,
so he really was someone,
a writer who was writing his great novels
when he was working at a power plant,
doing nice shoes. Um, and that is
the world that he knew very well.
So his circumstances were actually not
that far and move from the circumstances
of the London family
poor ways, obviously. Um,
so this is a picture of the House,
um,
25 years after he brought it and we
can see that it actually still looks a
little too private. It's very,
it's very stately shaped, uh,
used to be afraid grant house. Um,
but it's unpainted. And then Ashley,
not afraid, you know, even 25
years he saw owning the house.
It was nice. Still not repair. Um,
so basically you spend the rest of his
life trying to fix up that house. Well,
we also see there is his wife Istyle.
Um,
and it turned out it was very good
marriage and his bite of the haze, um,
it lasts for the rest of his life.
Um,
and here's the picture of the
two of them side by side. Um,
and so it's kind of a unexpected,
the trajectory for that unseemly
marriage, uh, back in 1929.
Um,
and so that's the family situation and
is probably very complicated relation to
his two stepchildren.
Um,
Polly do and what exactly
what constitutes a family. Um,
those questions would have been
front and center for Faulkner. Um,
in 1929 when he was writing this novel
about families in general about generic
poor white family,
um,
since the depression was right
there in the middle of August,
I thought that I'll show you a very
iconic picture by Dorothea Lange.
Uh, my mother, uh, 1936.
This is an image this reproduced over
and over again as the defining image of
the Great Depression.
Um,
and it actually is quite different from
the spirit in which as I lay dying,
uh, was written. So, um,
I think that this represents one way
to think about the great depression,
but actually the way that Faulkner
things about the Great Depression,
I argue is closer. Um, to
another class at work about, uh,
the rural South James
Agee and Walker Evans, uh,
collaboration, um, is a text
with lots of photographs.
It's a collaboration between the two of
them called let us now praise famous men.
And I'll just show you a few pictures.
A Walker, Evans, uh, pictures of,
um, what it, how it feels
to be a poor white, um,
in also the same year as the
Dorothea Lange picture. 1936.
Um, so, you know,
this is a little later after Wagner of
Finnish has already finished as I lay
dying,
but this is what the house of a
share cropper would have looked like.
And I think, um, the common
estimate was that 80%,
maybe more than 80% of,
of farm laborers in the south were
sharecroppers. They didn't own the land.
Um, so this is the
interior of the house, uh,
of the poor whites and other,
and here in the bedroom.
Um, and I love this picture is
Ellie Mae, um, beautiful phase,
very proud and very sad and very resigned,
but not giving up.
And that's exactly my
image of addy. Um, and as,
um, poor white. So anyway,
that is the background too as I lay dying.
Um,
and I think that we just need to,
we you about two pages,
two or three pages into
the novel to see it.
This is another highly experimental novel
experimenting in Different Points of
views.
And this is really a dazzling
array of narrators. Um,
so in the first 18 chapters,
these are the narrators, um,
and nobody, nobody has to
keep track of them. Um,
just pick the ones that you can remember.
Uh,
but they also tend to have
three distinctive voices.
They actually are very easily
recognizable, so don't worry, um,
that in fact there's no danger that you
get them mixed up. Um, so in order to,
um, talk about, um, this very rich, um,
establish of, um, of,
of points of views and styles
of speaking and speaking voices.
Um,
I thought I'll introduce to other
critics or theories about the novel Obama
Narrative in general, actually not
just about the novel because, um,
narrative goes much further back
than, um, than the novel. So the epic,
the Odyssey would be one kind
of ancient narrative. Um,
although Bactine very celebrated
Russian theories of the novel,
um, doesn't like the epic
are that much things.
The novel is really the greatest thing
replacing the APIC. Um, but in any case,
that's what he says about the novel and
what makes the novel so great is that
even though there's this illusion
when we just see words on the page and
everything seems unified,
that the novel is actually a highly
diversified genre with loss of internal
fractures. And what generates
those internal fractures,
um, is that there are multiple
languages in the novel,
which is what he says [inaudible]
is made up of social dialects.
It kind of touristic group behavior,
professional and Joggin's
generic languages,
languages or generations and age groups
can then show to contentious languages,
languages of the authorities or various
circles and the passing fashions.
So I think to express
authority or intentions,
but in a refracted way.
Um,
so we all know that that novels actually
do register passing fashions very well.
Right? So, um, uh, novel about a,
the valley girl would have to work like,
you know,
the light would be repeated constantly.
It wouldn't be realistic if it weren't.
Um, so that's the, it's the
nature of the novel. Um,
two is to mimic her and speech.
Um, and so [inaudible] is very,
very,
um,
accurate in his description
of the currency, uh,
and the way that the novel is always
up to date on the language that people,
um, uh, using actual living people using.
Although novels can also
choose to be historic novels,
in which case they will be try to mimic
the language or the 18th century of
whatever as pension, you
know, sometimes does. Um,
and is a master at doing that. Um, so, um,
so bacteria is great in terms of,
um,
talking about the social dimension of
language and I don't think that you guys
need to be reminded that this is directly
related to our discussion of social
types, right. And Hemingway
and Fitzgerald. Um,
so basically this is the social
dialogues of various, um, label, label,
label a social groups. Um,
but I think that as we read,
as I lay dying,
we can also see that there's something
else going on other than social dialects
that back teens theory actually is
inadequate to describing the spectrum of
linguistic phenomena.
And as I lay dying,
so to supplement Bactine,
I would like to introduce
one other critic.
Distinguished British critic died in
2010 a commode.
And this is actually a book
that he wrote earlier, um,
quite early in his career called
the genesis of secret safe.
The interpretation of narrative,
um, and about teens theory.
Um, is that, uh, that yes,
we tend to interpret narratives
when we given a narrative. Uh,
most of us attended to
interpret it in some fashion,
but his argument is also that narrative's
themselves our interpretations of
reality. So, you know, the, when we
actually try to interpret a narrative,
we actually doing a kind of Mather
interpretation in the sense that the
narrative itself is an
interpretation of, uh, of reality.
And not only that,
but that secrecy or sequence emerge
in the course of that interpretation,
which is a fascinating notion
of how secrets are generated,
not when we are trying to hide
something from other people.
But when we go about interpreting reality,
that is when secrets become a reality,
becomes a,
when they become a recognizable a
reality, maybe not legible, but, uh,
they become registered as a
dimension of reality. So very,
very interesting idea and
move basically, um, is,
is interested in the Bible that says
is great reading of the gospel of mark,
of Saint Mark. Um, and,
but he's also interested in
narrative in general. So let's,
um, think about how
his idea, uh, with, um,
could be,
um,
incorporated or combined with back
teens theory of social dialects,
uh, to think about the basic linguistic
paradigm. And as I lay dying,
so while I like to suggest is that we can,
uh,
very schematically,
classify speech in as I lay
dying under two headings.
One is the social dialect and it has to
do with functionally coders speech. Um,
when you're within a particular group,
a generic group,
um, because there's so much
commonality among that group,
quite often you would just use, um, a
shorthand. So, you know, for Liberals,
Sarah Pailin would be one such shorthand,
right?
You don't need to say any thing more
of his roof reference therapy. And,
and that's,
that's enough.
So that's one example of a currently
functionally coders speech.
Uh, it obviously is a dialect
of the subgroup is not
representative of the entire
population. Um, and, uh,
because it is so intimately
formative of our subgroup,
um, it, the,
the very use of language can function
as a socio economic and psychological
portrait of that subset of the population.
So this is very all witch,
all those concepts are very important
too about tea in that population is made
up of various subsets and their lines
of division among those subsets based on
the linguist usage.
So this is the social dimension and we'll
think obviously about how poor whites
would use the English
language. Um, but um,
almost move very beginning.
And we also see that the English language
is used in a different way and as I
lay dying, so those are the worst
with the secrets and it's very,
very hard not to read
as I lay dying without,
I'm sensing that those was
a pregnant with meaning, uh,
quite often were denied
access to those meetings. Um,
they sort of flaunt their toddlers with
a meaning that is not available to us
and that's part of the traction
and power of those words.
So I would like to think about those
words with secrets. Um, along two lines.
One is relatively short term
and relatively transparent
in the sense that we can
get to them sooner or later and the
other would be long running worse with
cigarettes,
um,
that are very resistant to
our investigation was to
hold on to the secrets for a
long time and maybe never
giving up the secret,
never yielding anything to the reader.
Um,
so let's start with the
easier part of the spectrum,
which is a very recognizable speech.
Um,
and I'm taking both those
examples from Cora who is, um,
I think it's fair to say is a fairly
good example of a poor weight.
Um,
so I saved all the eggs
and bade yesterday.
The cakes are turned out real well.
We depend a lot on our chickens.
They are good layers with few.
We have left after the
Parsons and such snakes too.
In the summer I had to be more careful
than ever because it was on my final say.
So we talked on,
we could have stopped cheaper chickens,
but I gave my promise and
as Miss Lowington said,
when she advised me to get a good breed
because Mr towel himself and miss the
good breed of cows or
hogs pays in the long run.
So when we lost so many of them,
we couldn't afford to use
the eggs ourselves because
I could not have had Mr Tao
chides me when it was on my say.
So we talked on so very proud woman.
Um, but obviously under very
difficult circumstances.
These are the people who cannot afford
to eat the eggs laid by their own
chickens, um, and um,
is because they lose so many chickens.
Um,
and just from the possums and the snakes.
And because those chickens
are so expensive, um,
they losing one means a lot to them.
So all of that,
which theme to be chorus responsibility.
And I think that this is really,
um, fatness, basic
portrait of the poor. Wise.
I'm very, very proud people
in spite of the poverty. Um,
we've lost some moral rectitude,
um,
in the sense that they're willing to
take our responsibility upon themselves
without recognizing that actually someone
else should also be held responsible.
The person who advises them to
buy all these expensive chickens,
which turns out to be very,
very bad advice but not a
word of complaint from Cora.
So what we can say about this world
is that this is a world and was moral
responsibility is tightly and capsulated
within the compass of the speaking
voice.
That there's the basic
coincidence incidents between
the boundaries of the self
and the circumference of accountability
so that you are completely responsible,
accountable, answerable to
anything that happens to you.
It is truly unfortunate that your chickens
get taken by the possums in his neck,
but it is your responsibility.
Um,
so Ms Lowington is reference is alluded
to but no blame is attached to her.
And I would say that this was really the
defining future according to Faulkner,
I'm of the mentality of the poor waste.
And we can see one other instance of that.
Um,
so I bade carefully. Cora has been told
by not intent again to do something.
So I bade carefully
more careful than ever.
I bet in my life and the
cakes turned out right. Well,
but when we got to town this morning,
Islams and told me the lady had changed
her mind and was not going to have the
party after all,
she wanted to taken those cakes anyway.
Case that well I say,
I reckon she never had no use for them.
Now she ought to taken them.
Kate says,
but those rich town ladies can
change the minds for folks. Can,
Richard's is nothing in the face of
the Lord for he can see into the heart.
Maybe I can sell them at a basalt
Saturday. I said they turn out real well.
Um,
once again,
the same mentality that we s that
we saw just in the earlier passage,
uh, that full encapsulation
of responsibility within
incumbents have a single
person,
um,
and that couple with a certain kind of,
um, psychologically redeeming piety, uh,
that even though something is be
falling unfortunate is the following,
the right now that God is the
ultimate judge of everything.
And once again,
there's the deep reluctance to
extend the blame to anyone else,
either. Ms Lowington, other rich town
lady who changes her mind about the cakes.
Um, so, um, this is, uh, um, I
would say a very sympathetic,
um,
although obviously critical,
both sympathetic and critical
portrait of the poor wife. And, uh,
it basically is the baseline is the
baddest given a linguistic given
psychological given the social
given in the world of SLA dying.
Um,
and just about everything else that
we see in the rest of the novel is a
departure is a deviation from that given.
So Cora is the styling
point and everyone else,
uh,
moves away a bit from that starting point.
And we can measure the degree of
deviation or maybe a degree of dailene's,
um,
because as I lay dying,
it's also about deviance
and the consequences of
deviance and to annul novel
that we sleep.
Um,
but this is a very important
starting point for Faulkner.
So let's look at the various points of
departure and most of departure from that
linguistic baseline.
And move on now to talk about the
various kinds of worse with secrets. Um,
one is very short term and I think that
you guys know what I'm talking about
doing del State Grid.
Um,
and then the long running asleep grid in
the bundling family coming into us from
Dow judo. Naturally I've
added one other vitamin. Um,
so, um, let's look at the
short cigarette Duda. Um,
and she, she was picking cotton
with leave, right? So, um,
and she's decided in her own
mind that if a bag is for,
then she would do something.
Um,
so the decision is hinting strictly
on whether or not the bag is for,
and it turns out that Labor
soon picking into her back.
So it was four when we came to the end
of the row and I could not help it.
And so it was, I could
not help it. It was then,
and then I saw Dow and he knew,
he said he knew without the words,
like you told me that Maya is
going to die without words.
And I knew he knew because if he
had sat in you with the words,
I will not have believed
that he has seen there,
that he had been there and saw us
police that he did know. And I said,
are you going to tell part? You're going
to kill him without the words I said it.
And he said, why? Without the words.
And that's why I can
talk to him with knowing,
with hating because he knows who this is
the first indication that the bundling
family,
my have something in common.
The House of Atreus is the importance
of the word heat in that family.
Um,
and it seems that hate hatred can come
about because someone knows something
about you and all of that.
All of this ferry into hands
exchange is conducted without words.
So in many ways, this is, you know,
fuck that obviously is not
responding to about 10.
He wouldn't have been thinking
about [inaudible]. Um,
but he's obviously thinking of a
dimension of language that is not covered,
that is not encompass by a social
dialogue and in fact is not encompass by
actual actually spoken worse other than
other two towers that those emotions are
going through. Do a doubt. Faulkner has
to use words to convey that, that, that,
that, um, experience to us. Um,
so Faulkner's using words but do though
is not using words and dao is not using
words either. And we know exactly what
it is that the downloads, you know, that,
that, um, that do that as in
fact go into town, you know,
because she is in such a condition,
um,
that she needs to do something about
herself. Um, and it all comes from, uh,
they've picking the cotton into her
bag and what happens with a bag is for,
um, so it really is a pretty
transparent cigarettes. Um,
and um, you know, I think the
offers are in the know, uh,
almost right there.
They're not that many secrets that a young
girl in her circumstances could have.
So this is almost the only secret
that she have and she does have it.
Um, so, um, that in itself was surprising.
It's not surprising that she
would get pregnant out of wedlock.
There's not surprising.
Um,
it is surprising that she would
hate dial so much because of that.
So let's turn out to the
more deep seated deep rooted,
uh, kind of see with, um, that
is not always disclosed to us.
Um, as the words are spoken, uh,
maybe not disclose to us as the narrative
unfolds and maybe never disclosed to
us ever. So, um, dow it turns out, um,
as in fact,
as soon as the novel opens,
this is the opening paragraph of SLA
dying right there in this very neutral
looking, um, statement from
Dow. This little secret,
Joe and I come up from the field
following the path in single file,
although I am 15 feet ahead of him.
Anyone watching us from the cotton house
can see Jews frayed and broken straw
had a full head about my own.
So it seems a kind of odd kind of
emphasis on the spatial orientation of the
bundle and how's the colony house and
what anyone in the cotton house we'd be
able to see.
And the difference in height,
the train Dow and Joel. Well
difference in height, you know,
is not public, not most difficult
thing in the world for most people.
Um,
but within the family difference in
height actually is kind of interesting in
potentially significant.
Um,
so let's just keep that in mind that this,
uh,
what seems to be a kind of a telling
difference in height between Dow and jewel
and just leave that stick with
bright there because Dow is not,
maybe dad doesn't even know himself.
Uh,
but he's certainly the carrier of a
secret that is revealed that is sort of
given to us or slung at us,
you know,
that we just met to receive this thing
that we don't fully understand at this
moment. Um, but this passage is, uh,
in many ways deceptive in the sense that
there's not any complicated language
and there's nothing that we obviously
don't understand, um, about the,
about it.
So I was still classified as being fairly
close to the do Dell kind of cigarette
is long running,
relatively long running but it
potentially could have the same kind of
transparency there as do Dell cigarette.
But let's look at um,
something I was where the language itself,
uh,
becomes very different and this is coming
from Joe himself and I really don't
actually think I can read this
very well so I would try it.
But for them it's only,
it's not making it easy for
anyone who tries to read this.
If it had just been me when cash fell off
of that church and if it had just been
me when pie late sake without low,
the woods fell on him,
it would not be happening
with every bastion in the
country coming into there as
well because if there is a god,
what the Hell is he?
Four it would just be me and her on a
high hill and me rolling the rocks down
the hill at the faces,
picking them up and throwing them down
the hill phases and teeth and all by God
until she was quiet and not that
got them as going one lake less,
one lake less. And we could be quiet. Um,
I truly don't know what
to say about this passage.
Other than that there's a lot of hatred
in there, just like Dewey, those passage.
Um,
and it seems that for some reason
hatred is the most powerful bond in this
family. Um, and Jill
seems these, you know,
one conjecture that we could have about
this passage is that he wants to throw
stones down the hill as someone.
Um,
and it appears that he wants to throw
stones at the rest of his family.
Um,
and we have no reason to understand.
It's not just that we are not good
enough leaders that we don't understand.
We actually have no reason to
understand what's going on here. Um,
because Faulkner does not want
us to understand at this point.
So all we know is that jewel
is furious about something.
He is furious that cash
is making a coffin,
um,
for Addie for some reason.
And he can stand that
as going one lake less.
That is the sound that he can stand,
um,
as well as the fact that Addie is on full
display for the entire neighborhood to
come and look at her, uh, when cash
is trying to get that coffin. Radic.
So these are the immediate circumstances
that he really hates that she is,
um, in disgrace because everyone,
every bastard in the country,
you can come in and look at her when
she was waiting for her coffin and the
calciums to be taking his time, making
the coffin, but not maliciously,
we would think.
Cause he's a very good carpenter and he
wants to be a thorough in making a very
good coffin. Um, but, um,
but for some reason Jewel's
hatred also extends to his father.
And if it had been him when that low,
the worth felt,
um, uh, on him, that
would have been good too.
So it, it's just really,
um, it's very peculiar. Uh,
we don't know, uh, the long history,
the long emotional history,
um, behind all those people.
They obviously are a very close knit
family because there are so few people
around that there's just not
enough distance separating them.
They're really basically all stuck in
the same place. Um, and that creates,
um, uh, kind of, uh, uh, the,
the ideal condition to maximize
any kind of hostility, uh,
amount of family members.
This seems to be one of the consequences
of poor ways in a very small town with
very few few neighbors. Um, so, um,
it seems at the very least that you as
he imagines himself or is he experiences
himself in relation to the rest of his
family that he sees himself very much as
an outsider.
Okay.
So Joe sees himself as an outsider
that he would like to do something.
He would like to throw stones
at the rest of his family. Uh,
and combined that with the fact that,
um, Dow seems to be really, uh,
fixated on that otherwise
innocent fact that Joe is,
um, whole head taller than he is. Um,
the dose to the same link in some
fashion. There's kind of a very, um,
deep seeded in violent and
always explosive kind of
hatred coming from Geo and
the neutral observation from
Dow, the dose to the uh, uh,
the pieces of some kind of jigsaw
puzzle that we have to figure out, uh,
in the course of SLA
dying. So let me just, um,
give one more addition,
uh,
to that kind of configuration.
Uh,
based on what seems to be unmotivated
or unaccounted for hatred,
the hatred is undeniable, the
violence is undeniable, um,
is just that we're not able
to read them very well.
So Franklin low is actually right that
this is a narrative that in the cause of
making us compelling us to come up
with interpretations is also generating
secrets in that very act that the fact
that we have to interpret the words that
are given to us also generate secrets
about the bundle and family. Well,
he just do it all back again. Um,
and we know that she's already, uh,
been the carrier of one kind
of secrets about herself. Um,
that seems pretty
transparent. Uh, but this is,
seems to be secret of
somewhat different order.
And jewel don't care about anything.
He is not kin to us in caring,
not care can and cash Lysol on the
long hot yellow days up into plants,
nailing them to something.
And I did not think that thou would,
that sits at the supper table with his
eyes gone further than the food and the
land full of the land.
Degaulle is cow and the hose feel
with distance beyond the land.
Um,
I think this is Ashley.
Thoughtless belated attempt to write what
he doesn't ride in the sound of fury,
which is the portrait of three brothers
toe from the standpoint of this sister.
Um,
do though is nothing like catty,
but it's almost as a father
is showing us that yes,
he can certainly capture a young girl's
point of view and maybe this is what
comes out. So not exactly
flattering or, uh, very,
uh, uh, is, is a very intimate
portrait of the three brothers. Um,
but it's not one that they
would especially invited
to see or hear about. Um,
so something about jewel,
um,
seems to be emerging just in a
course of what Dow is saying,
what Joe himself was saying.
And what do you do is saying that this is,
it's a common pattern. Uh,
the Jew is not kin to us.
He's not care can he doesn't
care for the rest of us.
His interest seem to lie
somewhere else. Um, so that, that,
that fact is, is, um, you know,
is, is fairly straight forward.
Um,
the little bit of observation
about cash is interesting.
Um,
we know that cash is a good carpenter
and Faulkner really want us to highlight
that fact. The basically he's the one
who brings in money to the family. Um,
he's the one who's always
hired by other people.
It's the only one who is capable of
bringing in real income into family. Um,
and he really wants to make a
good coffin for addie. So, um,
all that is not in dispute,
but the way in which duly doubt looks
a doubt that he's sewing up the long
heart,
said yellow days into plans suggest that
maybe there's kinds of metaphoric and
psychological dimension
to concentrate as well.
That even though he was
a very skilled laborer,
this also something very skilled workman.
He's more than just labor is
actually is an all listen,
it's very skilled artisan.
There is something about, uh,
that act of frame methodically sawing
the wood that says something about the
mindset of cash.
And so that is what do we
doubt is noticing that as if,
uh, even though no matter how
good and all the sudden he is, uh,
there's something maybe just a little
disturbing or worrisome about the fact
that he's so much into carpentry
and then for portrait of doubt is,
um, truly, um,
I don't know what to make of that is
very surprising coming from Dewey Dell,
um, who so far has not been
a very deep thinker or any,
someone with very deep emotions
actually. Um, you know,
she's worried about something very
immediate and very simple really. Um,
but this portrait of doubt that,
um,
that his eyes are gone food
and this food and the land,
he's not obviously not just registering
the food and the landers is different
degree of death between
what his eyes register, um,
and the quote service phenomenon
of the third and the land.
So there's a difference, um, in, in,
in, in just the radius of, of uh,
perception, uh, between
what Dow is registering, um,
and the most immediate physical
world, food and land. Um,
and I think that is because
of that difference in the
radius of perception, um,
that the whole land seems to be embedded
in his scout or dug out of the scout
and then, um, their holes
filled with distance.
That in some sense the vastness,
uh,
both the vastness of the land,
they're enormous distance
but also the holes,
the gaps in that distance of
those our path into Dallas skull.
Um, I mean I'm just paraphrasing
the, they're not really
elucidating that passage.
Um, and I think that that's
all we can do at this moment.
That there's something special about Dao,
uh,
that he's not so easily
describable in everyday language.
So this is almost a direct
reputation about teen.
That social dialogue quite often cannot
capture the psychological reality even
of what appears to be the most important,
you know,
deprive a person, um,
disadvantaged person.
Um, so I want to um, give
you one more example,
uh, of, uh, of, of uh, a
specimen linguistic specimen.
Um, and the specimen that
isn't the right word.
Specimen would have been the right word
for Hemingway would have been the right
word for, um, for Fitzgerald
in the short stories.
But they're strictly ironic in the sense,
but I use that word anyway. So this,
this one instance of language that is
also country completely incomprehensible
to us. Coming from a child from
vitamin, it is dark, I can hear,
would silence,
I know them,
but not living sounds now live in him.
It is as though the dark.
We're resolving him out of his integrity
into an unrelated scattering of
components.
Snuffing was in stampings,
smells of cooling flesh
and ammonia at hair,
and the illusion of a coordinated hole
of splodge high and strong bones within
which did hajj and secret and familiar
and is different from my ears.
I see him dissolve legs rolling.
I a Gaudy splotching
like co flames and flow,
the bond,
the dark and fading solution,
all one yet neither or either yet.
None.
I can see hearing called [inaudible]
caressing, shaping is hard shape,
fetlock hip,
shoulder and head smell and sound.
I am not afraid.
This comes right after
two very dramatic moments.
The chapter before development chapter
is when we know that Allie is that the
Eddie Bundra, there's like
that is announce towards the
very end of that chapter.
And then the chapter that is vitamins
chapter right after that is when he
actually goes into Peabody is
bond the bond or the neighbor,
um, and uses a stick to beat on the
horses so that they all run away.
And most of the, um, that chapter
is devoted to bottom and, uh,
beating on the horses and saying
that they not even the day,
but you killed my ma. Uh, so
that in itself is kind of,
you know, sort of understandable
but strange in that he would pin,
unlike Cora who would pin the
responsibility on herself,
vitamin pins,
the responsibility for killing
addie on it appears on Peabody.
Um, and that's why he's beating on
his horses. Uh, and, and in fact,
uh, you know, just destroying the whole
team. Uh, the, the horses run runaway.
Um, and then after the
peer buddies, horses,
runaway vitamins,
themes to be preoccupied
with something else.
And this is a moment where [inaudible]
really is having a great time.
If his pronouns of, you
know, who is this kid? Okay.
I think they are at least two candidates.
I think it possibly is,
is Joe's horse, you know,
this horse doesn't run away.
And there's something about,
there's nothings and
stampings and a splodge hi,
that suggest that it is to horse, um,
that, that, that volume is talking about.
This is the one thing that's remaining,
um, this horse that doesn't run away,
but there's also a possibility,
um,
that and is different from my is uh,
just because of the syntactical
construction or that
sentence suggests that it
probably, it might not be an animal, but
the human being I'm a human being who is,
is,
is different from vitamins is in which
case that human being could only be two.
Right?
So I think that this passage is meant to
be deliberately misleading in the sense
that we can tell exactly where Jude begins
and where his horse with jewel end at
way horse begins. Um, the boundaries
between the human being, um,
and the horse, um, and also clear cut
and in fact the identity. So the tube,
uh, same to the interviews. Uh,
and that is one of the great
innovations in as I lay dying, um,
those, uh, very ambiguous, uh, and,
and southern boundaries between
the human and the nonhuman. Uh,
which actually is also one of the great
defining attributes of the classical
attic tradition.
Um,
so we'll come back to this and talk about
the southern boundaries between human
and nonhuman, both by going back
to homer and Dante and so on,
but talking about the
implications in SLA dying.